Okay, let's go next to our caller from the
eight, six, two area code.
Who's calling today from eight, six two.
Does that mean
that is you?
Who is this?
Hello.
Hi there.
This is home from New Jersey.
Hey Sam, what's going on?
Um, I just had a quick question about, uh,
your previous comments on like the whole discussion
about private.
So private corporations like the social media
ones and the, the whole, um, Trump's, what's
at his executive order thing?
You defended that?
So, um,
wait, I defended Trump's executive order.
What are you talking about?
No, no, no, I that was, that was ms braids.
Sorry, Ms Misspoke.
The, the, the, the private companies, how
they have the right to like, you know, host
what they want on websites.
If I'm, if I'm misrepresenting you.
Sorry, but I just wanted to kind of like quickly
remind you of what that, so my question seems
contextual.
So, um, I had a question about how you feel
about, uh, their targeted ads.
Like specifically Instagram and Facebook.
I don't know if you heard but, or like experienced
this yourself, but it almost seems like just
having a discussion with people around like
your phone or your computer, you'll go onto
like Instagram or whatnot and they will be
targeted ads just about things that you were
discussing, like say one, like a new video
game, right?
Or something like that or, or anything along
those lines.
And I go on Instagram and within five minutes
I see an ad for something like that.
Yeah, yeah.
This, I'm, this is not, I mean, so let me
talk about this a little bit for people who,
so I don't think that this is, my understanding
is that this is not the platforms that are
doing this.
So basically my under, I have a little bit
of an understanding of this.
I've tested this a number of times.
So at one point I was thinking of getting
a particular sneaker and it's a sneaker, I'm
not going to say this sneaker brand because
they're not paying for ads and it just doesn't
really matter, but it's, it's sort of an obscure
sneaker brand.
So it's not like I had been saying the name
of it regularly and I mentioned it to my girlfriend.
And then the next day I got ads on Instagram
for that sneaker company.
Um, and as a test she said a difference.
Like I found an obscure sneaker brand and
we talked about it and she started getting
ads for that sneaker brand.
The next day.
Same thing happened with a Boston sports club
that was opening a where we mentioned it and
I started getting ads for it, so this is happening,
but my understanding is that this is not the
social media platform that is quote doing
this, that this is information that is available
for advertisers to take advantage of when
they want to advertise on different platforms.
So I'm not, I'm just not sure that it's accurate
to say that, that that's something that Twitter
is doing.
I think this is a function of the way that
you have your phone configured.
I think it has something to do with, someone
told me if you turn Bluetooth Bluetooth off,
that won't happen.
Although that doesn't totally make sense to
me, but yes, I know exactly what you're talking
about.
Okay,
so solution to that, but I don't see, I don't
see how those two things could be connected,
but yeah, I guess my question about it would
be, well, whether it's social media companies
or not, do you feel like because they are
hosting the ability to do that, if it's not
them directly, yeah,
they're allowing you to target on that basis
for sure.
Yeah, I would agree with that.
Yeah.
Do you, do you find that to be an intrusive
thing or do you think that that's that that's
allowed as something that a private corporation
should be allowed to do?
Well, so again, we have to distinguish what
it is that we are talking about.
I find it intrusive and creepy.
I find it intrusive and creepy on a personal
level.
Now we are granting our phones, the permissions
required to do this.
The strongest argument I've heard is we're
granting it without even really knowing it
because who really understands all of those
terms of service and the permissions that
you're granting your phone
read them.
Exactly.
But I find it absolutely creepy and intrusive
and now there's a counter argument, which
is, listen, if you're going to see 10 ads
a day, no matter what, isn't everyone better
off if they are more targeted to your interests?
But that seems to me sort of like a red herring.
Yeah.
Okay.
And I just had one more quick question if
that's all right.
Yeah.
Um, so you have a sort of, not, I wouldn't
say flippantly, but because you know, you
say you don't really do as much cupboard for
the people pulling at 1%, but, um, you've
stated prior to that ending the actually a
previous call, you know, Tulsi doesn't really
have a chance of becoming the, uh, Democratic
nominee.
And I, I agree.
Uh, I'm a personally a Bernie supporter, so
it's not like I'd be voting for her anyway.
Sure.
But in my opinion, uh, well how you, we're
over tumble, but Bernie Yang and Tulsi are
probably my top three, even though the latter
two pretty much have every chance.
Okay.
At this point, you know, I kind of agree with
your assessment, but I want to know what your
opinion is on the fact that even though Tulsi
pulled very low, she met the donations, restaurants
threshold and polled, well not well above
but, but enough on plenty of polls that would
otherwise be considered legitimate if not
for the DNCS random, uh, you know, requirements
that don't seem to, that seem to be rather
obscure.
And I want to know what your opinion is on
that.
Like should she have been allowed in the debate?
Like do you think that those, do you think
that those, the polls that, that cited her
as having pulled above 2% should have been
taken serious?
Listen, my opinion, it's sort of like whether,
whatever I think about which polls should
have been included, it wasn't a secret which
Paul's counted and it was known which polls
were counting long before it was known who
would meet the criteria in those particular
polls.
So like, I think the DNC does a lot of terrible
stuff.
They are gatekeepers in many ways that I find
to be destructive.
But the idea that after seeing that if certain
polls were counted, Tulsa would be in the
DNC, decided we're only going to count other
ones.
That's just not the way that it went.
The, the polls that we're counting were decided
ahead of time and it just, I have a hard time
feeling outraged about it.
I do.
I wouldn't say I'm outraged about it because
I wasn't, you know, I wasn't going to vote
for her in the first place because like I
said, I'm, I'm more of a Bernie supporter.
Yeah.
Um, I guess, I guess then you could back it
up from there and say, do you think that that
practice of only picking specific polls, which
certainly, um, favor the DNC preferred candidates,
cause you know, there's, there's, there's
plenty of evidence that they over vote over
select, you know, older voters, et cetera
and things like that.
Yeah.
We've looked in detail at a lot of the polls
and most of them are not over sampling older
voters.
They are accounting for the fact that older
voters are actually more likely to vote than
younger voters.
And I think that that's a completely legitimate
thing to consider, but uh, listen, I mean,
the problem is if you have no standard, then
anyone can just get a poll done.
You can just perch, you know, anyone can can,
can fund a poll and you can demand that it'd
be done in a certain way and then all of a
sudden it's like, well, there needs to be
some kind of line.
All right.
Fair enough.
I,
I understand that answer.
Um, thank you very much, David.
I appreciate you taking my questions.
All right.
Thank you.
Appreciate the phone call.
Let's take a quick break.
If you are on hold, don't hang up because
we will go right back to the phones after
this.